and hey it's a big day over at circa the
hotel tower officially opens today
circa is the first resort built from the
ground up in downtown
in four decades and we have a great look
for you this morning hector mejia
live to give us a live tour inside good
morning hector isn't it gorgeous
hey there alex it is gorgeous it's my
first time up here and check this out
this picture from i'm
not even sure when it's from but it's a
black and white photo from way back in
the day from the dunes
this says an elephant at a playing table
surrounded by people
you probably will never see that happen
nowadays now in 2020
and this is the 60th floor up here at
legacy club we have these oil paintings
founding fathers here in las vegas and
off over
in this direction we have some gold bars
valued at 1.8
million dollars but it even gets better
we have a million dollar view from up
here
we can kind of see the first sun rays
peaking from the mountains
let me uh take you outside this is the
rooftop
lounge area that actually opens today
along with the hotel tower
once it's a hundred percent complete 777
rooms will be part of the hotel tower
and just look at this view
look at it it's just you know magical
and not to uh
sound like i'm exaggerating it's always
you know pretty breathtaking when you
see a view like this
we are on the 60th floor and we also
have new video
as fresh as this building from a few
minutes ago showing the very first
guests checking into the new circa
resort in casino
well they checked in on saturday the
first round of guests and it's been
dubbed
the world's earliest check-in because
people were allowed to check in
two days early for free and people we
talked with said
they were beyond thrilled to be here
this is exciting we're so excited to be
here for this
new era as they call it the new era of
downtown
we're making history we're going to be
the first ever to sleep in that cool bed
upstairs so we're pretty stoked
and i bet you people are snuggled in bed
right now since they got checked in days
ago this will be channel 8's home base
for a new year's eve coverage
our team will be taking you through
every time zone we'll go live from
stadium swim
downstairs as well as from the legacy
club up here we will be socially
distanced
doing covet screenings and following all
of the guidelines and back out here live
i mean here's another view of the uh
the view up here from the 60th floor
with the hotel tower opening
this is the final phase of the
property's grand opening and we were
here back in
october when the world's largest
superbook
opened when the casino floor opened and
now we're here
as the tower the hotel tower gets ready
to open
officially today reporting live from
circa hector mejia
eight news now back to you yeah best
views in las vegas hector enjoy it up
there it is
gorgeous thank you it's chilly though